threads is trending racking up new
members by the tens of millions just
hours after going live
catching on really fast if you only look
at the numbers
and it's of course
uh mostly due to the fact that it's an
Instagram app and it seems like Fred's
aims to capture or seize the opportunity
uh while Twitter
suffers a number of setbacks in the in
terms of popularity
Twitter owner Elon Musk has been under
Fire for making changes to the platform
most recently limiting the number of
tweets users can binge in a single
session on the streets of Santa Monica
some social media users welcome
Twitter's new competitor I think it's
great it brings a little bit of organic
approach to a new environment because
Twitter is very you know very prominent
um so I think threads will at least give
them a little bit more insight of how
other people think you know outside of
Twitter others seemed wary of even more
social media so are you going to go on
threads I'm not going to be the first
one I'm gonna watch and see what's
happening I'm not just going to go and
follow everybody you know that's not my
vibe to Mars Fred's represents another
battle between two of the world's
biggest Tech Titans with musk even
challenging meta CEO Mark Zuckerberg to
a cage fight Zuckerberg posted on
threads feels like the beginning of
something special but we've got a lot of
work ahead that work could include
fending off a lawsuit from Twitter
musk's company says meta built up
threads by hiring dozens of former
Twitter employees who had access to
commercial secrets
the growing rivalry between two of the
world's richest men may be of little
consolation to the thousands of
employees both companies have laid off
in recent months
Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Santa Monica
California